riquet casalino chef du service
d'urgence à l'hôpital bichat à paris
professeur henrique casalino bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors pour commencer peut-être
qu'en est il de la situation aujourd'hui
dans les hôpitaux à paris la situation
commence à se tendre
je ne vais pas dire que nous sommes en
difficulté ce serait exagéré mais il est
évident que progressivement nous
commençons à atteindre des niveaux
d'activité qui nous font craindre que
nous ayons des difficultés à assurer
l'ensemble de nos activités nous devons
continuer dans les hôpitaux et nous
occuper des infarctus d abaisser de la
chirurgie oncologique du traitement du
concert de toutes les activités les
l'infinité des activités et de
dimensions différentes que peut avoir un
hôpital aujourd'hui au moins 30% de nos
lits sont occupés par des patients qui
ont le coc vide un tiers par une seule
pathologie
ça peut si ça continue mettre en
difficulté notre capacité à accueillir
les autres situations et accueillir
aussi davantage aux deux passions qu
vide
nous avons une énorme contrainte de
personnel se sont pas uniquement les lie
c'est que notre capacité à augmenter le
nombre de lits comme lors de la première
vague pourrait être réduite par des
contraintes dans la gestion de notre
personnel alors les admission en
réanimation il loupe dans les hôpitaux
tout l'été en jour
cela veut dire quoi que les capacités
d'accueil risque d'arriver à saturation
en novembre si ça se poursuit comme ça
pour donner une image extrêmement simple
un patient qui rentrent en réanimation
il va rester en moyenne entre 3 et 4 5
semaines vous imaginez bien que la
vitesse à laquelle ça rentre est
beaucoup plus rapide que la vitesse à
laquelle ça sort donc nous risquons dans
les trois quatre semaines à venir de
nous trouver
avec un taux d'occupation de passion
kobe extrêmement élevé d'avoir à
sacrifier d'autres segments d'activité
dans l'hôpital afin de dégager du
personnel pour les réorienter sur les
secteurs qu'ovide
que ce soit en réanimation ou en
médecine et nous notre obligation
d'assurer toutes les missions de
l'hôpital tous les patients doivent être
accueillis la sécurité de tous les
patients doit être garantie et ça c'est
quelque chose qui peut se trouver
compromise dans quelques semaines s'ils
ne nous commençons pas dès maintenant
avoir une attitude extrêmement
rigoureuse et à prévenir que cette
nouvelle poussée épidémique un autre
monde et ne nous met pas en difficulté
alors pari du coup en zone d' alerte
maximale c'est inévitable selon vous
c'est nécessaire même rien dit et
inévitable mais je pense que aujourd'hui
le temps de la discussion de l' échange
de je suis d'accord tu n'es pas d'accord
je pense que c'est fini
aujourd'hui nous sommes arrivés au
moment de l'action il faut toute
complaisance vis-à-vis du virus se
seraient en faveur de virus ce serait en
faveur de mettre en difficulté le
système hôte hospitalier ce serait de
mettre en danger nos aînés de mettre en
danger nos familles et ce serait en
faveur de condamner un certain nombre de
patients que s'il ne s'infecte est pas
un certain nombre de personnes que si
elle ne s'infecte est pas elle ne
déciderait pas il n'aurait pas dû décédé
ce sont des morts évitables que nous
devons aujourd'hui nous battre pour
qu'elle ne se produise pas et au niveau
des lits en réanimation à ce que les
cliniques privées pourraient vous
apporter leur aide ce qu'elles ont été
d'ailleurs sollicité sinon pourquoi
finalement ne pas mobiliser davantage le
secteur privé le secteur privé avait été
très mobilisés lors de la première vague
épidémique et il le sera également comme
nous tous nous sommes un système
hospitalier dans lequel il y à des
activités privées et publiques pousse
tous la main dans la main tout le
système de soins doit répondre
hospitalier de vie
e le médecin généraliste comme le
spécialiste l'hyper spécialistes dans
tous les domaines tout système de santé
doit répondre aux besoins de la
population c'est comme ça que ça avait
été lors de la première vague
c'est comme ça que ça devra être et se
saura j'en suis convaincu s'il y avait
une nouvelle poussée épidémique
si vous me permettez je fais juste une
métaphore nous voyons dans l'horizon un
feu rouge
on ne va pas freiner juste quand on
arrivera sur le passage clouté
on doit commencer à freiner dès
maintenant c'est dès maintenant que tout
le respect toute la rigueur dans le
respect des mesures barrières de la
distanciation social le port du masque
sait maintenant que ce doit être fait
pour éviter que nous arrivions à une
situation critique
une dernière question concernant la
prise en charge des patients qu'on vide
à ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est
meilleure aujourd'hui est ce que les
patients restent moins longtemps à
l'hôpital
oui nous avons fait des progrès nous
avons nettement améliorer nos capacités
diagnostic nous avons nettement
améliorer l'identification des filets
optimale pour les patients nous avons
nettement améliorée des stratégies
thérapeutiques pour nombre de cas nous
savons que nous pouvons réduire un
certain nombre de d'évolution
défavorable chez des patients qui ont
des marqueurs biologiques ou des
critères de sévérité
nous sommes dans ce sens là aujourd'hui
mieux outiller la difficulté reste
néanmoins que ça reste une maladie qu
une fois qu'elle est présente
symptomatique et qui nécessitent une
hospitalisation et l'érable
elle peut avoir des critères de sévérité
il peut être associé à une mortalité
relativement importante à l'hôpital un
tiers des patients en réanimation vont
décéder et la réanimation est une
épreuve extrême défis extrêmement
difficiles et pour les patients et pour
leurs familles
je ne souhaite à personne de connaître
ça j'en pense qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
tous être solidaires être responsable
est trop rigoureux et protéger
l'ensemble nos concitoyens ce sont nos
hôtes
étude individuelle qui protège la
communauté merci beaucoup henrique
casalino d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes chef du
service d'urgence à l'hôpital bichat à
paris